the team for the most recently completed
decade was announced yesterday by the
national football league and how about
tom brady you know i've said in the past
and this was an idea that mds first
tripped over that tom brady could be in
the hall of fame
two different times
pre-2008 post 2008 and tom brady making
it on to
two all-decade teams one of the
unanimous selections for the decade of
the 2010s not a surprise he's the first
quarterback to make two all-decade teams
and only 29 players have ever done that
where they've made the all-decade team
twice
yeah it's uh it's amazing just you know
put it on his tab another another
accomplishment for tom brady but you
know just it speaks to the guy again tom
brady yes he did he had two hall of fame
careers and what i can't you know again
i can't give him enough credit for i
really can't you know early on in this
decade
it wasn't stellar it wasn't it went to
the point where you know i know i was
vocal about i got new england people
that hate me then where i was going man
you know brady in 2012 2013 it wasn't
looking good and that's why they drafted
jimmy garoppolo but a credit to him just
to he changed his throwing techniques he
obviously changed his lifestyle off the
field as far as his eating and that
seemed when that whole thing started to
go up the tb12 process and uh yeah tom
brady i mean just unbelievable how long
how consistent he's played at such a
great high level
yeah you're absolutely right and really
if they were ever going to wave the
five-year waiting period for anyone it
would be for him i mean this guy is
going to be in the hall of fame first
ballot without question unanimous one of
the best players if not the very best
player in nfl history there were eight
total unanimous selections on this
year's or in this decades uh all decade
team tom brady adrian peterson joe
thomas
marshall yanda jj watt aaron donald von
miller and justin tucker none of those
are a surprise chris all of those guys
are deserving not only to be on the all
decade team but to be unanimous
selections yeah unanimous selections and
that list right there they're like
that's unanimous first their their first
ballot hall of famers to me too that
group so yeah i'm not shocked i mean jj
watt and aaron donald are as good as
interior d lyman as we've ever seen
marshall yonda and joe thomas are both
you know guards and tackles that are as
good as they've gotten in this era
adrian peterson's one of the three best
running backs all time we know von
miller how special he is so yeah that's
a special special group there that's a
gold jacket group uh to me so you know i
i didn't have too many problems with the
list overall you know i know some people
were like surprised at the drew brees
aaron rodgers right that's the one thing
i saw on social media oh drew brees got
screwed over again you're crazy aaron
rodgers the best player of the decade i
don't know what anybody's talking about
i mean and first of all
i'm stunned yeah i'm stunned i don't say
that i'm stuck
i keep it real more russell wilson i saw
more russell wilson
better than aaron rodgers for the decade
nobody even would say russell wilson was
a top three quarterback until like last
year but now they want him on the all
decade team people talk out of both
sides of their mouth a lot of these
people who said that i know i saw that i
want to go you didn't even think russell
wilson was good three years ago but now
you're gonna say he's the all-decade
quarterback aaron rodgers won two mvps
he easily could have won three and four
i mean he came in second i believe two
or three times in the decade he's been
to four nfc championship games he had
one of the greatest super bowl
performances we've ever seen in this
decade he was a champion in this decade
he can't help that his tight end
couldn't catch a onside kick against
seattle or he would have been in another
super bowl i mean to me it's just that
that's not even a debate uh whether
aaron rodgers should have been on there
and i am i know i love aaron rodgers but
i keep it real if i didn't think he
deserved to be i would i don't think
he's the best quarterback in football
anymore i've come off come off that you
know i love him but he's not the best
right now
think about how great the quarterback
position has been in the nfc over the
past decade when drew brees and russell
wilson don't make it right right two
guys who are both going to be in the
hall of fame both are going to be first
ballot hall of famers and they don't
make the all decade team that just shows
you how much competition there is at the
quarterback position right now in the
national football league and we still
are in this golden age where you've got
this nucleus of older quarterbacks who
are still chugging along and this group
of great young quarterbacks who will be
dominant on this decade's all-decade
team patrick mahomes etc etc so yeah
look i i agree with you ultimately it
should have been aaron rodgers but i was
surprised how much pushback was out
there for russell wilson as a potential
alternative they're really well and you
know what i i kind of like it when
when
they they they screw this up because it
gives us something to sink our teeth
into i the only thing that jumped out at
me from the all decade team they have
tyree kill as a punt returner how many
punts has he really returned
yeah you're right he only had that
little two-year period i want to say
like 2016 2017 you know maybe in the
2018 where he did it a little bit more
but
you know i guess they're looking at it
nonetheless he's the greatest weapon
we've seen of the decade and they
couldn't put them on the list of
receivers because the list of receivers
is insane in the membrane with antonio
brown larry fitzgerald calvin johnson
julio jones i mean that's a freak show
respectfully and those are all first
ballot hall of famers so yeah i'm with
you but you know who else who else do
you put in there i guess would be the
the big thing i don't know if they
needed two kick returns and punt returns
you're right they probably could have
just had devin hester's the kick
returner and darren sproles as the one
punt returner
one thing they didn't do this time this
was something mds noticed yesterday they
didn't have first team and second team
they just named the team
and obviously the people who made it
unanimously they are cut above the
others but when you don't have first
team and second team
that that could make it harder
to make cases for potential
hall-of-famers because if you say the
guy's a first-team all-decade selection
more likely to get in second team a
little bit harder no team designated
yeah you've got that element that's now
taken out of the mix chris
yeah no you're right it's uh another
notch people or another pelt on the
horse that guys can say you know as far
as their case stating their case for the
hall of fame to go look i made you know
second team all decade you know once or
twice whatever it may be but that is all
gone uh and and yeah but you know again
you know i kind of like it this way i do
i think expanding the team and making it
you know just one team makes more sense
to me than anything else i have one
other issue i'll say if i'm going to be
totally transparent here and i can't
help myself i don't like patrick
peterson on the team i'm sorry you know
again i i have a hard time swallowing
that one i know patrick peterson's play
has been worthy of it but patrick
peterson got suspended for eight
football games they got to reduce the
six for pd usage and then got caught
trying to cover up the ped usage so
here's that's one guy that you know me
mike i have a hard time with that kind
of crap you know you cheated you broke
the law you did a lot of different
things there that i don't like let alone
being a setting a bad example for young
kids i would have put a keep to leave
over patrick peterson i'm sick of him
being in this era of glorifying cheaters
i'm sick of it it's bothering me and all
sports and stuff like this like oh you
cheated hey you're on the all decade
team well i don't know he might have
been cheating his whole career so maybe
he's not as good as we know i don't know
and it's not just it's not
the issue of glorifying cheaters
it's this refusal by fans to recognize
it
to properly chastise and downgrade the
achievements of those who have tested
positive for peds and in peterson's case
it was the combination of the positive
test and
the the
detection of a masking agent which made
it right six-game suspension last year
how long was he successfully masking
that's what i mean failure of the
masking agent we wouldn't have known
he was using it and he was using
something else to cover up that he was
using it and maybe for a period of
multiple years he was getting away with
it but finally the testing caught up
with the substance that's usually what
happens the testing will catch up with
you that's why you need to stay a step
ahead of it and that's where he failed
how long was he cheating
yes that's all i'm saying and and and
it's so it's and it's not we're
glorifying it it's that there isn't
enough
outrage there isn't enough
uh i we're just i it's so weird how fans
get upset with baseball players who
cheat and when football players do the
attitude is well how the hell else do we
expect them to show up and play every
week
yeah well yeah no they're capable
they are i mean you know
they don't need to do peds for a lot of
these a lot of these guys are in the nfl
because they have a dna structure that's
freaky or gifted that way you know half
the guys in football are part caveman
and neanderthal you know so they're
built to play football if you saw a lot
of these moms and dads out there like
you've already heard me say i mean if it
ain't for barbara sims you know the big
f for my dad's mom i mean there's no way
i play in the nfl or big phil plays in
the nfl i mean i've said before grandma
sims she she had some hands and could
have played middle linebacker in
football she was 5-11 big square
shoulders and she'd beat you up so
a lot of these guys can handle but yes i
have issues with that i do we fail to
recognize that at times and we just kind
of let it slide by and i don't like that
and i don't mean to sit here and take
personal shots but it it bothers me as a
competitor and it bothers me as a human
let me go back down a rabbit hole then
uh um and it's not like i need to entice
you down that rabbit hole we already
talked about tom brady we talked about
how early in the decade he wasn't
performing up to the standard we had
seen in the prior decade that was your
opinion and look it was it was borne out
by the fact that they went 10 years
between super bowl wins and we did see
after the on to cincinnati game in 2014
something clicked something happened
do you believe that he should have been
impacted in any way by the deflategate
situation well i i don't i'm not going
to say all right so there's one thing
here
you know again you know i don't like it
and do i think people gloss over this
subject too easily you know i do yes uh
it's it's the negative for tom brady for
me
if i ever have one negative thing to say
about him it will always be that where i
just go damn i don't get it and yes of
course i think he's guilty but um the
other thing i'll say where i can defend
tom brady in a lot of ways is go okay he
got you know they got busted for the
flake gate but then they went and played
in super bowl 49 and we know the balls
were checked you know properly for that
game against the seattle seahawks and he
threw lasers and missiles all over the
field and played as good as you could
possibly play against one of the best
defenses we saw of the decade so to me i
can swallow that one a little bit more
especially with the results that we saw
after that but it does bother me yes and
you know to take the air out of the
balls which most most coaches in
football would tell you too you know
there was a reason a lot of people
thought new england didn't fumble at
home in new england and had other issues
like that it's easier to catch the
football so yeah that's certainly a part
of the discussion but you know i i again
i'm not going to put brady and patrick
peterson's uh camp there because he
to me ped usage and going down that way
going down that road is a little more
severe than you know taking the air out
of the footballs which i still don't
love and it's still cheating in some
ways
and look you know where i stand on this
i continue to believe the evidence was
inconclusive that there was cheating on
that day now that doesn't answer all the
questions that that emerged during the
investigation but for that day the afc
championship game in early 2015 i
believe the evidence at best was
inconclusive that there was any type of
shenanigans with the air in the
footballs one more point before we go
mds and i have been i'm sorry i've been
multitasking i got a business to run
copy paste snarky comments so i'm trying
to yeah
i posed the question to my writing staff
as to whether or not we are barking up
the wrong tree by suggesting tyreek hill
should not be
the
all-decade punt returner with 85 total
punts in the decade mds tells me that
tyree kill ranks 25th in total punt
return yards for the decade and that
devin hester had more than twice as many
punt return yards as tyree kill and a
higher yards per punt return average yet
hill
is the all-decade punt returner instead
of devin hester that makes no sense and
that just feels like somebody who had an
agenda to wedge take a kill onto this
team some way somehow even if he
otherwise didn't fit in the category
where they put him i think that great
work by mds you the man big guy uh but
yes yeah i think that's exactly what i
said i think somebody just looked at it
and said man this guy's such a great
weapon and he's been such a game changer
we need to just get him on the team and
you know that that's not right either
you know i don't like that yeah you're
taking away other people's spots there
he's an awesome player he's certainly as
good as we've seen but i don't know if
he deserved a spot on the all decade
team i mean look at it this way
devin hester at some point is going to
be considered for the hall of fame and
it's not going to be easy for him to get
in because special teamers have a hard
time getting in if he's the all-decade
kick returner and punt returner stronger
argument to get the guy into the hall of
fame right
so that people deserved it not i don't i
don't care that they needed to find a
spot to stick tyree kill they crammed a
square peg into a round hole
devin hester not tyree kill all right
mds is going to be writing that up for
profootballtalk.com
we've we've accomplished something here
this morning we have we found something
to complain about in the all decade team
and we'll have another copy paste snarky
comment posted pft on that subject
although there's really no copy paste or
snarky comment this is our own idea
that's your own idea right it's our own
idea so i wish you would shut up with
copy paste and snarky com
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports